at the end of the day I think I'd rather
be with my kids well that's what
Christine's decision was no I'm just
telling you there's been a bit of a
Civil War the whole family in a way and
I'm looking at Janelle wondering whose
side she's on Cody and Janelle Brown at
odds again in the Sister Wives finale
the lead up to the big reveal that
they're separated Janelle has made it
pretty clear to me that she's
enjoying her life without me so are you
separated yes we are separated and it
took a lot of work for us to figure out
how to navigate it so it was it's
definitely been a challenging year Cody
and Janelle continue to argue about
holiday plans amid his strained
relationship with their adult children
there's a general disgruntlement among
my kids you've hardly been around Cody
you're not seeing all the input you just
like they should respect me and because
of that Janelle feels like she's had
enough I do think you could focus like
you're like oh my God nobody wanted to
be together and to be honest with you I
really don't know if I want to do the
work like I'm basically it feels like
I'm being forced to choose between my
children and this group I'm just like
what what
sorry I don't even recognize
this family or whatever like I
like I don't know something has really
changed for me and it seems like
something did change for the mom of six
in a teaser for the upcoming Sister
Wives one-on-one special Cody and
Janelle announced their split after
nearly 30 years together I think if we
both really sat down we'd look at each
other and say really we've been
separated for several months what
so are you separated yes we are
separated
but it looks like Janelle and Cody's
relationship isn't the only one on the
rocks in the finale Mary expressed her
feelings about Cody wanting to work
things out with Christine who left him
last November but not with her it's
kind of disturbing because like some of
the things that he's frustrated about
with Christine he did to me oh he wants
to work on it with Christine
but
not me I am still here because I'm still
trying six years later I'm still here 10
years 15 20 years later I'm still here
it's what I want as with all
relationships you know whether it's
spouses or friends or family or Sisters
You've Got the ups and downs you just do
and it's just a matter of what your
commitment level is but Cody he's
singing a different tune I'm exhausted
like who cares if you're not with me
you're against me f off
you know I'm just like that way
ironically Mary's trying to support me
and I don't want to be in a relationship
with her anymore yeah the brown
patriarch is even questioning if plural
marriage makes sense for him anymore
maybe we've done something wrong along
the line we've certainly like asked God
to guide us and help us
I don't want to blame plural marriage
but just hasn't worked very well for us